[Musica]
di solito gli speech the Ted gravitano
attorno al concetto di ottimismo
Ottimismo sempre come un sole è una
stella che illumina chiunque gravi
Cattolica Tuttavia stasera io volevo
provare con voi Adagio nati intorno a un
dilemma ansia un paradosso
e non è un Tato spiritoso non è un
paradosso che si può risolvere in poco
Anzi in genere porta angosce forte
inquietudine non è da sabato sera
il paradosso è questo ma il mondo che
noi abitiamo che calpestiamo è frutto
dei nostri migliori sogni oppure è un
incubo
perché sei un sogno non dobbiamo fare
altro che continuare a sognare e
migliorare il mondo ma si come dicono
per cui corrente ambientalisti voi Ci
avete rubato i nostri sogni se l'uomo è
un problema perché arrogante come
distrugge tutto Allora siamo capitati in
un incubo e non usciamo facilmente se
non per il bene del mondo
allontanandoci dal mondo gli
antinatalisti un movimento che da poco
sta cominciando a prendere corpo di
Chiara maniera spudorata e onesta di non
vuole più fare figli perché ogni figlio
messo al mondo è una quota di carbonio
in più che noi consegniamo alle
generazioni future
Allora peggiorato da questo dilemma
tocca raccontare la storia del mondo
lunga complicata piena di sfumature
mettono convinto di uscire da contare in
poche battute
perché la storia del mondo in realtà è
la storia di due blocchi due paesi il
paese di Pinocchio
il peso di MasterChef
non possiamo andare
perché Pinocchio perché MasterChef
Pinocchio
Collodi grande domando italiano si è la
storia di un burattino che cerca
disperatamente di non perdere la tua
infanzia perché con l'infanzia c'è
l'avventura la curiosità ma è anche uno
dei più grandi studi gente affreschi
sulla fame la fame e la miseria che
c'era in Italia negli anni
tutti i personaggi di Pinocchio hanno
fame il sogno ricorrente tutti i
personaggi Pinocchio mo solo mangiare
mangiare andare finalmente nel paese dei
balocchi dove tutto è a disposizione di
tutti
è bene questo paese c'è il peso di
Masterchef il paese dell'Abbondanza oggi
andato in qualsiasi supermercato e
qualsiasi ristorante Quello è il paese
di MasterChef è il paese dei balocchi il
paese in cui Pinocchio sarebbe dovuto
entrare
possiamo fornire i parametri anche
giusto per misurare i due mondi il paese
di Pinocchio è durato 10.000 anni se
prendiamo la data l'origine
dell'Agricoltura diecimila anni fa
simbolica quindi lunghissimi fai così
così lunga 10000 anni e spese di
MasterChef da piccolissimi così gli
ultimi 80 anni nel paese di Pinocchio
cioè 12 dati due parametri che
definiscono le condizioni di vita
l'aspettativa di vita e la mortalità
infantile
aspettative di vita dei nostri genitori
Agricoltori in piscina anni fa
35 anni 35 anni e facevi la cartella e
del
1980 5 anni
non perché se morisse 35 anni ovviamente
perché la mortalità infantile era
altissima che avevi detto a Tally molto
probabilmente Vorrei vedere arrivato a
15 anni quindi la media abbassata e oggi
nel paese di MasterChef Noi siamo noi
italiani 83 anni
83 anni
la mortalità infantile è bassissima
Quasi inesistente tranne una dozzina di
Paesi dell'Africa subsahariana qualche
paese della dell'arte
bene questo da un po' la misura del
cambiamento si può dire che è rimasto
del mondo e la rincorsa da Pinocchio A
MasterChef una forte questa storia mi
sembra troppo teorica
sabato sera allora ci sono scrittore mi
voglio far vedere una lista principale
del paese di Pinocchio
questo facevo dirà mai questo conosco è
già aperta Eccola qua lo conoscete
ma il mio nonno conosco nonno nonno
Antonio nonno contadino con i vostri
nonni contadino meridionale Vedete qui
ritratto con l'unico rischio della festa
un vestito aveva io vado Non puoi
raccontare un giorno Andò al matrimonio
vendo so quando torno il cane non lo
riconobbe lo aggredì
Ma perché penso mio nonno perché mio
nonno nato fine 800 se fosse trasportato
con la macchina del tempo del 1005 1800
1006 sarebbe accorto che sta in un'altra
epoca avrebbe continuato a fare le cose
che faceva a fine 800 inizio 900 la
realtà che nel paese di Pinocchio
l'agricoltura non è mai cambiata Sì
certo e bassi però città molto ricca
cioè raccolti abbondanti Ma nella
sostanza la media della Destra di
cereali costante questo lo sappiamo
possiamo anche fare un gioco prendiamo
un etto di terra che questo bicchiere e
noi sappiamo
studiando anche gli archivi che mi ha
bloccato ma la tardo Impero da un etto
di terreno 10.000 stati 10.000 m
potevamo tira fuori una tonnellata di
grano
apposta fa una una capacità di ricordare
Ok facciamo sto gioco da te simbolico di
snodo in quella storia è cambiata Come
cambia il rapporto facile Ok tanto il
medioevo
Michelangelo scolpisce La pietà
d'origine di Nascimento Quant'è rapporto
è sempre una Una Ok
effetti qualcosa si muove origine al
movimento che poi stai con
100-150
scientifico Quant'è la media è una una
1751 da Lamberto pubblico il primo
volume dell'enciclopedia tutti sapete
non so libri illuminismo Quant'è 11 13
luglio
1789 Lady Oscar muore sotto la Bastiglia
data importantissima Quant'è il rapporto
1160 seconda fase si possono industriale
1 1 1900 interpretazione dei sogni di
Sigmund Freud 1 1
non cambia comincia a cambiare Nella
seconda metà del 900 cioè dopo la
Seconda guerra mondiale perché perché
arrivano per grande innovazione che
porto sopra della media
3-4-5-6-7 Tutto cambia Guardate un po'
dal 900 come è cambiato il mondo
Eccolo qua grafico di Robert
Vogel Premio Nobel per l'economia nel 93
se non sbaglio questo grafico una
considerazione due variabili che si
muovono insieme sull'asse verticale la
cresce della popolazione ha diverse
miliardi 8 sull'altro di Zonta le
l'innovazione tecnologica Come vale
un'azione tecnologica e come va della
popolazione partiamo le diecimila anni
fa quando appunto nel mondo secondo i
calcoli di Vogel molto ottimisti c'erano
solo 10 milioni di persone quanta
Lombardi oggi il mondo era abitato da 10
milioni di persone quasi tutte Lombardo
fratello anche interisti milanisti non
lo so comunque non cambia nulla Guardate
nulla cioè paparazzo in non cresce non
sta decisione innovazioni tecnologiche e
poi nel Novecento impegnata Noi siamo su
quella bici è lì 8 miliardi ancora più
su so che usa questo grafico per dire
che il ventesimo secolo è stato un
secolo rimarchevole notevole
meraviglioso
e ho dice Foca Scusa non ho capito Ma tu
veramente stai facendo ma veramente file
Il Novecento un secolo meraviglioso due
guerre non c'è l'uscita fusibili si dice
Attenzione il secolo in cui Abbiamo
sconfitto la fame la carestia la
malattia la morte prematura di un sogno
questo
aspetta di vita comincia a stare
tantissimo perché perché mangiamo meglio
e mangiando meglio rafforzare il nostro
apparato immunitario e con due semplici
pratiche geni lavarsi le mani bagni
piastrellati le fognature e la scoperta
degli antibiotici alla pensilina noi si
rafforzano aumentiamo aspettare di vita
siamo papà si tutela accelerazione
tecnologica e il mondo Cambia Cambia
perché moriamo di meno e dunque io nasco
nel mio 166 e c'erano 3 miliardi di
persone
Emilia di
474 faccia mia prima vacanza a Rimini
nato miliardi di persone meno 187
seconda vacanza a Cambridge Dove compro
anche un album dei Rolling Stones Still
life bellissimo album dal vivo 5
miliardi
1199 ho fatto niente però c'è un altro
miliardo di persone
2010-2010 ho scritto un articolo sul
Messaggero un giorno è domani per dare
il benvenuto al bambino del Bangladesh
che simbolicamente portava la cifra a 7
miliardi siamo otto miliardi adesso
78-79 arriveremo a 10 miliardi di
persone
questo è il paradosso abbiamo poi non
abbiamo sognato un mondo migliore che a
me non hai visto Ho chiesto cosa vuoi
per il futuro ha dei bambini non
vogliono più sono stanco ma ogni volta
che muoio bambino di dire Eh la Madonna
se l'è portato via Sono stanco di questo
voglio pensare tanto e cena Voglio
viaggiare è questo mondo
abbiamo sognato un mondo migliore Sì
abbiamo prodotto più persone 8 miliardi
di persone che incidono impatto sul
pianeta terra Ognuno di questi 8000 di
persona desideri a sogni vuole mettere
le foto su Instagram
Voglio andare in vacanza ti voglio far
vede' pure io vado in vacanza nei posti
esotici è un consumo di energia è uno
spreco sono desideri legittimi come
vedete i sogni si trasformano in incubi
che dobbiamo fare perché è facile dire
facciamo gli ecologisti che dobbiamo
fare con 10 miliardi di persone che
prima della popolazione che piacerà eh
Ci vuole un po' di tempo che facciamo
sogniamo oppure un incubo e ce ne
andiamo dal pianeta
che facciamo
Io vi proporrei di non fissarsi troppo
nel ti sogni il mio sui vincoli se uno
sogna troppo diventa anche un po'
arrogante Pensa se la posso fare cado e
mi rialzo facilmente cosa faccio quello
che voglio io cliente un po' arrogante
esibizionista
egocentrico e non vede i danni perché
gli incubi segnarono anche Dani ma se
uno guarda soltanto i danni
e i costi gli incubi
paura non faccio più niente
ma devo anche dialogare collettivamente
perché se empatia aumenta bisogna
restare dialogare sogni in cui mettere
le mani in pasta Anzi dico secondo me
Qual è lo scopo della vita Lo scopo
della vita e fare il pane
perché ho iniziato col mio nonno e
finiamo con mia nonna
Mia nonna è morto il 74
è morto e sul letto di morte Sapete
quelle degli funebre ha chiesto a mio
padre un pezzo di pane
hai due di notte e Doctor pane si
ricordava Però più che c'era una
panetteria in una campagna in un posto
desolato la pelletteria tempi son Forna
che era soltanto una luce
sull'uscio
cerbiatto Erano tanti anni che non ci
andavi ti avviato con l'ombrello e ha
visto la panetteria entrata e c'è la
stessa aria che lui quando era bambino
usava per avere il pane Mio padre ha
trovato basta età di notte c'è sempre
qualcuno che fa il pane s'è preso il
pane e la porto da mia nonna mia nonna
ha mangiato e ha avuto la classica
miglioria della morte
Cioè hai sentito felice comincio a
sorridere e racconta il mio padre tutta
la vita la vita ma mai raccontato un po'
di nonna parlava non mi hai parlato Hai
parlato sul letto di morte e ha
ricordato dei fatti personali da bambino
un serpente metallizzata incantata e
campo di grano e suo nonno Cioè è suo
padre
aveva ammazzato medico dato anche i
soldati lo ha conosciuto la prima e la
seconda guerra mondiale dato le donne
che con l'età me buttavano il letame nei
campi e lo prendevano per far nascere i
campi di grano ha raccontato tutta la
sua vita ed è morto in pace
Se noi facciamo il pane facciamo un
gesto collettivo cioè non è vero che si
fa il pane in casa il faceva sempre
tutti insieme e facciamo due operazioni
La prima è
diamo la pace e moribonda non è una
cattiva cosa una cosa bella andarsene
ricordando Quando è stata bella la vita
andassi col mio nonno che ha detto se
potessero indietro nonostante privazioni
io di fare tutto è una cosa bella e poi
la seconda cosa possiamo diventare amici
cioè possiamo collaborare con tutte le
persone
siamo otto miliardi diventeremo 10
miliardi non possiamo risolvere i
problemi da soli non risolveremo Oggi è
impossibile i suoi primo fra cent'anni
probabilmente e ci sarà bisogno di
persone lungimiranti che hanno la
pazienza di aspettare
abitare
nel tempo insieme agli altri Insomma ti
porta pane porta anche la pace pace e
bene a tutti grazie